goodness this is kami done this already
yeah sorry they'll kill the guards like
Tom Tom help today they make the top
azucar Tom tell us what will you do it
sure I'm tu marking their senior
marketing man hi it's just nervous the
camera ok I'm used to analogy um ahem
but so to help help might bring me in
here and what I'd like to do with Tom
and also Brad maybe I'll ask Brad first
since he's been our chaperone for this
experience so here we are you can take a
pan and check out this place this is uh
this is putting a kid in the candy store
literally in my case I love love
chocolate and sharpen burgers right up
there the top of mine my top 10 so we
have this enormous selection of
chocolate and goods and tools for making
truffles mine broke so i might be
getting one of the scoopers what are
some your therapist I mean you have this
entire place with every possible variety
truck motor job I mean what are your
personal your personal pick at leas just
opinion on the vast objective absolute
or something I think I have to be honest
and say that it changes day to day okay
I wake up every day and I try something
different and I might appreciate
something why not okay but I I really
still love our seventy percent
bittersweet I think that just good I
just has the part seventy percent cacao
has the perfect sugar level and cocoa
level which is that's right over there
permanently rising that's right over
here yeah yeah i was looking at this
earlier because like i mentioned this is
actually the exact chocolate that I used
for my troubles this one right yeah
[ __ ] this is our bacon bar and this is
nine point seven ounces 275 grams and
this is our sort of bread and butter
this is our first product it never came
out of it oh really it's hard you let
it's our reach but when Kyle Sarah yeah
someone that John chef burger and Robert
Steinberg first came up with and they
made it then you know made it with a
hair dryer and no kidding oh that's
awesome yeah so this note this is an
important point so you guys would be
coming out with chips or chunks
potentially with with with some of these
Andrew so yeah I'm exploring that
exploring the option has nothing
confirmed same or open its great call a
little bird told me and i'll tell you
why that's important for me as a
consumer of chocolate is let's get a
vacuum yeah so if i have that bar it's
gone within an hour and if i have this
how many grams sources you have 275
grams 275 starts SI it's just about 10
ounces yeah so 275 grams here's the
problem with 275 grams and tim ferriss
being in the same room is that you have
I guess that's what nine calories a gram
and carbohydrates with a four-and-a-half
calories on a say-so anyway you're
looking at somewhere between let's say
two thousand at 2,500 calories here
which is probably you know three or four
times the daily caloric intake of a
Victoria's Secret model so i would down
this in the span of a few hours and
really probably not feel all too well
after that so I'll really be thrilled
when we get some smaller little bits and
pieces and that's actually we're done
this earlier but part of the reason that
I tend to have higher percentage cacao
chocolate in my house if I have it in
there at all because I'm not tempted to
eat a pound of it I'll have a couple of
little pieces here and there with a
glass of wine and it tends to keep the
moderation in its proper place okay so
we have the seventy percent on that
oh he needs I have a food we've just
launched this this fall and these are
pouches of five grams squares that we
sell so perfect for someone like you
want something to nibble on right but
doesn't want to have to finish a whole
three ounce bar oh yeah exactly so we've
got 70 62 and 41 we've also got this if
you you know just a milk version if you
like it or just a 70 version but this is
a great little product for folks like
you want to keep a little little snack
on hand cool the other thing I wanted
yeah all right so Tommy Tom wouldn't be
doing his job so if you weren't plugging
so well and all us we have got the best
milk chocolate in the country okay I
like it that's call me that huh free
legal lets me say that all right good
but I believe it and it was working low
opinion we go yeah exactly ah yeah I
guess it was a big debate when Scharffen
Berger Masha was about three years ago
developed a milk chocolate bar it was a
little bronzer 10 long in that baby
sharpen burger really known as the
darker well child art all about torture
so but whenever Scharffen Berger
approaches a chocolate we try to
redefine it and what's the sharper
burglar way and these guys did a great
job they did this way before I came with
a great job coming up with what I think
is again the best shot dark milk
chocolate in the country it uses less
sugar and more milk and a very high
quality milk that they searched heart
far and wide to find and it has a very
dark caramel flavor and if you ever do
one of our formal tastings where we
generally take you down from a we start
with the dark flavors and come down a
little bit into the bittersweet the
semi-sweet and then we end it with an
old topic you probably really were
working on it we I didn't I didn't take
too many bites out of any ninety-nine
percent but we need to do 80 do you do
that and then you get to the milk truck
and if your milk
which I yeah when you get to our milk
chocolate you're just in seventh heaven
I mean it is just fantastic oh this is a
great job I'm all for it I mean we see
here we do we ended up consuming a
decent amount of chocolate and actually
related to your your milk chocolate
where are the almond bit seesaw all
right yeah this is what we were eating
earlier this is this is the plate that
ended up being empty so this is the
41-percent and then with the sea salted
almonds god love it y'all so y'all saw
traveling he hands the milk maybe oh so
you learned what nippies when we had we
tested a number of different noobs yeah
milk Navy's a great one there's a little
texture so what now from a marketing
standpoint all right so this is for the
people who can justify watching this
entire video saying they took home a
business lesson ah what are you coming
up on Valentine's Day good I guess two
weeks away more lies is that the biggest
day of the year people to me do you have
is that something that you really focus
on well you know for Scharffen Berger
the biggest time of year is actually
holiday season we have a greatness Chris
manager in there a new years it's sort
of you know October on right and reasons
we have a strong heritage with Baker's
pastry chefs one of our biggest
proponents from the start and she still
works with
Alan symmetric who I pronounced that
right no better excuse me and she ran
owned a series of pastry shops in the
Berkeley area and knew Robert blades
together and has cooked with Scharffen
Berger chocolate and recognize how we're
cooking chocolate so that is a huge part
of our our bush valentine's Day is an
important holiday but a little less
important for Scharffen Berger than the
bacon see when now sue this is actually
you bring up a good question which is
when you're dealing with gourmet
chocolates yeah you have not just the
consumer market but you have the the
trade one yeah and so how what
percentage roughly view of your business
would you say it falls into both those
two categories or how are your customer
base is segmented out in that sense well
I tell you the way I think about it we
know I think of our pastry chefs and out
there as the key influencers right right
and so we like to do things that really
speak to them because they actually
influence all the consumers out there so
we just actually completed something
called a chocolate adventure contests
you can find it online at chocolate
adventure contest com and it was a
conscious where we invited people to
explore the boundaries of chocolate and
cooking not just in baking but also in
cooking all together and that's a great
example of how I mean I think we think
we want to really reach out to those
pastry chefs and cooks and
influencers in a way that hopefully will
have trouble down in fact on the rest of
our business sure so totally a big part
of our marketing efforts is reaching
outfit what's the future for Scharffen
Berger in any any particular visions
well they could of course be your
personal opinion well hey yeah we'll be
on a couple things once I think we're
going to continue to strive to put out
what we think is America's finest dark
chocolate I think the other thing you'll
continue to from us as will continue to
redefine what chocolate is and we're
gonna keep pushing the boundaries of
what you can do with chocolate well put
this man give this men are raised it was
very good present for me on the spot did
you see how well he responded to
pressure that was like this I just I
grab pull them aside in the area well
I've been writing this that I actually
gave him a script earlier he's done a
good job had all impromptu way he is
alright well hey guys I'm going to get I
think I'm going to have that hot
chocolate that generals tell me about
earlier and I put off someone to clean
palette tap all the other chocolate but
now that we've gone through the whole
spectrum and the taste testing down and
have a few gallons of hot chocolate
because it's rainy outside and I want to
prolong this experience so until next
time I've had to go
you